hello there fortnight fam
it's been four weeks since we last went
over the changes in the world
fortnite battle royale now we're in week
seven of season five the snow is melting
and the first update of 2021 has dropped
so sit your butt down for 10 minutes or
more likely five this week
please think about using code adam arrow
to support these shenanigans
and let's do this
so the christmas period is over the snow
has dissolved and the island has
returned to its default position
the christmas trees have left us as has
the store in retail row
there's a definite lack of changes this
time around but there are a few
worth mentioning firstly get your butt
over to the coliseum and you'll be able
to find a new variation of this area
one of which involves water any idea why
would this be in the update
i kind of want to have a community meet
up here at some point so if you have any
ideas on a community game
please let me know and i'll be skalking
around in the comments
[Music]
okay now the big one the huge update
have you visited stealthy strongholds
since the update
because there's a key change there a
spaceship has landed in the mists of the
jungle
i think it's safe to assume this is the
ship of the predator
last month we talked about all the clues
to the predator coming to fortnite
such as the trapped helicopter in the
tree line the village close by
and the predator signs on the doors here
all
from the movie and now look at the
secret part of the battle pass to see
the predator helmet his spray tag and
even a nod
to his infrared weapon this all points
towards the hidden skin for the season
may be becoming the predator and
hopefully he'll be a hostile npc to
battle too
but this gets a little more interesting
after reading the patch notes
they tell us to look at stealthy
stronghold but they also state
two hunters are coming a pair let's
break down what this could mean
my guess would be the supreme hunter the
predator and the hunter who took him
down
dutch aka arnold i'm not gonna say his
last name because sometimes youtube
thinks it's a slur
so let's move on and if you haven't seen
the predator movies old or new
it's about muscly men holding hands
totally
what more could you want but who else
could be the second hunter maybe a
female variant
maybe another alien i can't wait to find
out
also in the update are tons of new sound
cues around the jungle which sound very
much like the predator
noises
now we just wait to find out when he
arrives
there is a third update with the
inclusion of a new shotgun
a lever action version like the one seen
in cowboy flicks
but you know me it got me thinking i
began to look for well-known hunters who
used this type of weapon
and once again arnold came to mind and
this dude the
terminator the t-1000 a pretty iconic
hunter i'm sure you'll agree
in the terminator series the t-1000
reloads this weapon
in the same way and oh my it looks so
badass
so i think at some point we will get the
terminator as a new hunter
i would totally be down for a terminator
version of an ltm
that only has lever action shotguns and
miniguns
that would be damn good but i'm
digressing i'm moving away from the
point this is about changes
we know the predator is coming but who
would the other person
be
so there were a few small updates
between our last two meetups that
weren't big enough for a video of their
own so let's
recap them now during week 4 a
mysterious rift appeared
by walking nearby we could see the world
of the walking dead
from a cosmetic standpoint this was to
sell us more skins
hashtag code adamaru thank you but from
a story perspective
this was to show us the volatile nature
of the zero point
connecting to other worlds seemingly
without warning
was this because of agent jones meddling
or was this without his knowledge
at all a few days later another slice in
time appeared this time with an
intergalactic doorway
it was to sell us more cosmetics but one
of those
was black panther and i've got to admit
that trailer
hit me in the fields and to make sure
we've documented everything that's gone
on over christmas
the snowfall this year fell only in the
lower right hand corner of the island
over camp cod
and ending just above retail row the
green spots we looked at last time were
to house these micro airport stations
donned with christmas goodies and of
course christmas trees
so many christmas trees and i think
that's everything isn't it
let me know if i've missed anything i
shall leave you with the new year
celebrations in fortnite from 2020 into
2021
thanks for coming back after a month
away and a massive thank you to those
people who continue to use my code even
though i wasn't uploading videos i truly
appreciate you
here's a bunch more legends on screen
i'm adam from playstation grenade
all the best for 2021
[Applause]
[Applause]
you